CHET HAASE: Hi, I'm Chet Haase,
an engineer on the
Android team at Google.
In a previous episode, I
talked about ListView
animations where we would remove
a view and then animate
both the swipe of the item out
of the ListView as well as the
collapse around where the item
used to be, animating all the
other views into place.
So that was all good-- you can
run that kind of animation on
the property animation
system that goes all
the way back to 3.0.
The demo I'm going to show you
today looks remarkably similar
to that, but there's an
important twist to it.
So first let's see the demo.
If you want to go back and watch
the previous show so you
have some context with
that, that's fine.
OK, you're back.
Here we go.
Let's run the current demo,
and this should look
remarkably similar to
what we saw before.
So we swipe an item out.
If we swipe it a little bit, it
animates back into place.
If we swipe it further, it
animates out, and then it
animates the gap to be closed.
So here's twist.
If we run this on Gingerbread,
which is on my Nexus S here,
you can see this
same animation.
So this is a question I get a
lot with my animation demos
is, gee, all this property
animation
stuff is really cool.
How would I do it on
older releases?
Hopefully, that issue is
going away over time.
But if you are concerned about
Gingerbread releases still for
your application, then maybe we
can see how you could get
this kind of technique even
on that older release.
So let's take a look
at the code.
I'm not going to go over all the
elements of the code-- the
background drawing, and the
shadow, and everything that
was in the previous talk.
Just go ahead and check out that
other DevBytes, as well
as the Google I/O animation talk
that that demo came from.
Instead, I just want to focus on
the aspect where we're able
to run both the new property
style animations as well as
the older animations.
So in our touch listener, we're
listening for these
swipe events.
And we're doing essentially
the same thing--
we're listening for the down
event, and we're tracking
where that down event occurs.
And then in the move event, we
figure out where the new
x-position is to figure out how
far to move this thing.
And at this point you might be
thinking yeah, yeah, yeah, but
we're actually using
TranslationX.
We're using a property that
doesn't actually exist on
Gingerbread.
So how does that work?
That's the key.
So before we could get the
TranslationX value and we
could set the TranslationX
value, and these are view
properties that came
in in 3.0.
On Gingerbread, those properties
don't exist on
view, so it's a little
bit difficult to
work with them there.
So instead what we do is call
this setSwipePosition.
So I refactored the code so that
we could do the correct
thing on either release,
Gingerbread or
non-Gingerbread,
PostGingerbread.
So in that method,
setSwipePosition, you can see
how this works.
So if runtime is
PostGingerbread, this is what
we did before.
We simply set the TranslationX
value, we basically pop this
item that we were swiping over
to the appropriate place, and
then we set the alpha value to
be more or less translucent
based on how far away it was
from the original position, or
how close to the edge
of the screen.
If you're on Gingerbread, those
properties don't exist,
we don't have Alpha, we don't
have TranslationX,
so what can we do?
We can work with the old
style animations.
This is the animation system
that existed prior to 3.0.
Well, we can use that if we're
actually setting these
properties and faking the way
the view looks so that it
essentially looks the same.
It's not quite the same because
there is no alpha property.
But it is more translucent, so
it's effectively visually the
same thing.
So we can set a
TranslateAnimation on the item.
We can set an AlphaAnimation
on the item.
And we can create an
AnimationSet to bundle
both of these up.
We add both of these
animations to the
AnimationSet.
We setFillAfter and FillEnabled
to true, which
means they're going to hold
their value even when the
animation is over, and
then we're going
to start the animation.
So basically we set up the
animations on these things.
And we're going to effectively
set the alpha and the
translation property of this
item by running these
animations to a particular
value.
And notice that we're actually
running the translation
animation basically from the
current value to the current
value, which means we're going
to just slam it in there where
it's going to start and
end at the same value.
And even though the animation
is ended, we've set
FillEnabled to true, and
FillAfter to true, which means
that they're going to
stay at that value.
So that's the trick to actually,
not animating the
swipe, but actually setting the
swipe to be at the right
position under the
user's finger.
OK, so that's setting the swipe,
but then we have the
other behavior of actually
animating the
thing after it's removed.
So we come in here and say, OK,
when the user lifts up, if
they were swiping this item,
then we want to figure out how
far to move, and then we want
to animate the swipe.
So we call this other method
down here-- again, we've
refactored this into a separate
method where we
either do the Gingerbread
thing or the
PostGingerbread thing.
PostGingerbread, this looks
similar to it did before.
If you saw that other video,
we animate, we use View
Property Animator, we're
animating alpha, we're
animating TranslationX.
Here we use a listener, so
actually this animation will
work all the way back to 3.1.
There's no dependency on the
Jelly Bean API with end action
in View Property Animator
anymore.
Instead we just set a listener,
and when the
animation ends then we do the
appropriate thing-- we restore
values, we animate to close
the gap, all that stuff.
If we're running in Gingerbread,
to animate the
swipe, this looks remarkably
similar to what we saw before
where we were setting
the swipe position.
All we're doing is animating
the swipe position now.
So we're starting from the
current x and the current
alpha value from wherever that
item ended up, and we're
animating either off the screen
or back into place.
Again, we're using
an animation set.
We're no longer setting
FillEnabled because we don't
want the whole [? devalue ?]
when we're done.
Instead we're just going to
animate off or animate back.
And when the animation ends,
then we either restore values
to where they were if we're
animating back, or we animate
the other views, and for this
one, we want to animate the
gap closed.
So using the same technique that
we used in the previous
DevBytes video, we figure out
where all the views are and we
associate those view positions
with the itemId.
So we're using a stable ID array
adapter here again, and
we store these in a hash map.
And then we remove the item
from the adapter.
That forces a notify data
set change that
will force a layout.
But before that layout is
displayed on the screen, our
onPreDrawListener in the
ViewTreeObserver kicks in.
And we can now track the
positions of all the views in
the current version of the
ListView and figure out what
itemIds those are associated
with, compare them to the
other itemIds, and animate
the changes.
Again, all of this is
the same as before.
The only trick here is how to
actually make it work in
Gingerbread.
So we remove the
PreDrawListener, we figure out
where things need to go, and
then we run the animation,
which is right here.
moveView runs the animation to
actually shift these things on
the screen.
Again, we have a Gingerbread a
non-Gingerbread version of
this thing.
The non-Gingerbread should look
remarkably similar to
what it did before, except in
this case we're actually using
ObjectAnimators, sort of
interchangeable with View
Property Animator.
View Property Animator is
a little bit more of a
streamlined API.
I happen to use object animators
in this case.
In the Gingerbread version,
again we're using a
TranslateAnimation, pre-3.0
APIs, and we're saying, OK, I
want this view to move from the
current start and end x-
and y-positions.
And those were calculated
according to where the item
contents were before and
after the layout
change on the ListView.
And we set the duration,
and we start the
animation, and that's it.
Really fairly straightforward.
The only trick was that the
old approach was using
properties that didn't exist
on view prior to 3.0, so we
can't use that.
So we use the old animations
instead to fake the system out
and make it look the same.
And then the animation, same
thing, we're using animation
APIs based on properties, didn't
exist prior to 3.0.
So instead, we'll use the old
animations that didn't use
properties, but give the
same visual effects to
what we were doing.
Everything else is the same
logic-- track the itemIds
before and after, where the
views associated with those
itemIds were, and then
simply animate the
changes and that's it.
So go ahead and check out the
animation talk called "A
Moving Experience" at Google I/O
to get a little bit more
glimpse into how the demo
actually works and the
reasons behind it.
And check out the other DevBytes
videos to see the
overall structure of the code
and some of the other elements
that I didn't talk
about today.
And check out the code
for this demo.
Thanks.